Joe after spending what 1.3 million on
legal fees for crude in 2011 you
expressed concerns about being able to
make documentaries in the future
especially about legal cases yeah so
what changed and how are you able to
make YT yeah well as you know the crude
lawsuit was very draining emotionally
financially psychologically and actually
that was in 2010 and there was one day I
was sitting at my kitchen table with my
wife writing some very big checks to
lots of lawyers and you know and I said
if something doesn't change you know we
could lose everything
luckily things did change and you know I
emerged from crude from that lawsuit you
know okay but I had become disillusioned
about whether documentaries can really
affect a change and if this is the price
you have to pay maybe I need to rethink
my career but then that year was
bookended beautifully in August of 2011
a year exactly a year later from that
day where I was writing all these big
checks it was announced that the West
Memphis Three were getting out of prison
and of course the film's you know the
Paradise Lost series played a big role
in that because it was kind of those
films you know well I don't want to take
full credit or even anything close to
that because a lot of very unique
circumstances came together and tens of
thousands of people you know very
generously agitated for the woman you
know the release of the West Memphis
Three and notable celebrities came in
and you know a unique set of
circumstances came together to release
the West Memphis Three or to put
pressure on the authorities but the
films were the catalyst for that and so
after having had a horrible year getting
clobbered in my lawsuit against Chevron
I had you know the opposite experience
where I saw the power of documentaries
that you know films can effect positive
social change that they had a deep
impact on on the West Memphis Three case
and thankfully that renewed my spirit
and I got out of my doldrums and I you
know carried on and so the next big
project that came along was the whitey
bulger film and you know luckily CN n
films encouraged me to make that film
and so I did not have to struggle for
financing on that one CN n you know paid
for it so it wasn't really so much about
the money it was more about the
emotional fortitude it requires to make
these kinds of films to enter into these
kinds of worlds the battles you have to
undertake to you know get your story out
there and after the crude experience and
you know I had I had a little bit of the
life drained out of me but thankfully
with the release of the West Memphis
Three I'm back in business and and Mae
decided two men decided to make the
whitey bulger film
you